cal une chose est certaine le ballon du
mondial 2002 présente des présente des
performances tout à fait me dis qu une
vraie petite révolution technologique
les explications de patrick esther vous
n'êtes pas obligés de me croire mais ce
que vous avez sous les yeux c'est le
ballon de la coupe du monde de football
en gros mais alors en très gros plan une
image de la structure de sa peau
réalisée au moyen d'un microscope
électronique démonstration le ballon
officiel 2002 fournis par adidas est
composé de plusieurs couches de
polymères et de tricot de textile en
revanche une sphère de latex cet
assemblage permet de transmettre à la
balle de façon idéale toute la puissance
du coup de pied du joueur
le traditionnel ballon en cuir
appartient désormais à la préhistoire du
football ici le plastique dans lequel
les pièces sont découpées apporte une
précision sans précédent
la version 2002 dont la forme est
contrôlé au dixième de millimètre et 25%
plus précise que celle utilisée en
france en 1998 à la grande stupeur de la
star de manchester united david beckham
je pense que c'est le ballon loin plus
haut point que j'ai jamais draper je les
utilise et plusieurs fois on peut
obtenir une telle puissance telle
précision du tir
c'est véritablement exceptionnel si par
exemple vous demandez un pied robot de
shoot et vous constaterez qu'il rebondit
toujours de la même façon une
authentique révolution pour les
attaquants qui peuvent lui donner de
l'effet obtenant des trajectoires
inédite
enfin si le pied qu'il frappait assez
puissant ce ballon peut voler jusqu'à
130 kilomètres heure c'est à dire 13 de
mieux que celui de 1998